puedes añadirla en un aderezo para
ensaladas o comerla con alguna proteína
pero ahora la mostaza el famoso
condimento francés es cada vez más
difícil de encontrar en las estanterías
no hay mostaza he intentado buscar y no
he encontrado nada de tombet y no hay
mostaza en las tiendas
no solo es difícil de encontrar sino
también más cara la mostaza ha subido
más de un 14% de precio este año la
escasez causada por la falta de un
ingrediente esencial se encuentra en
esta bolsa en una fábrica de mostaza
semillas de mostaza
hay dos grandes exportadores canadá y
borgoña pero desde octubre de 2021 las
semillas no se cultivan no hay un pase
en gran canadá el mayor proveedor
mundial de semillas de mostaza se
enfrentó a una sequía histórica en 2021
que destruyó un tercio de su producción
una temporada de cosecha desastrosa
junto con la guerra de rusia con ucrania
otro gran exportador del condimento
significa que no se pudieron exportar
semillas a francia para hacer frente a
la escasez los productores de mostaza
están dispuestos a pagar un alto precio
por lo suministro y los agricultores
franceses esperan aprovechar la
oportunidad como ven una cola que está
dispuesto a aumentar su cosecha de 30 a
40 hectáreas de mostaza el año pasado
nos pagaban 1300 euros por tonelada este
año el precio ha aumentado un 100%
porque esperamos dos mil euros por
tonelada
agricultores como colas no esperan que
los beneficios les protejan de las malas
cosechas de los próximos años para
protegerse de una futura escasez la
industria agrícola francesa está
dispuesta a producir más condimento en
casa